the plan b pill a judge ordered that the
morning after pill which is known as
Plan B should be available without
prescription for anyone of any age
within 30 days now normally it has to be
taken within 72 hours of unprotected sex
there's been all kinds of court cases
about this I think basically this is
pretty good because women and girls
don't want to do this this is an
emergency situation and of course the
right wing is going to make it seem like
Oh everyone's gonna have these plan B
parties and they're gonna be snorting it
popping those pills like crazy what what
what do you think I mean do you think
that this is this is just a good thing
and we shouldn't even be thinking about
it I think that it's a great thing
because you know what teenagers have sex
and everyone likes to like neglected
except for liberals of course we talked
about it we said like we'd eat it we
need to make sure that they have the
comprehensive sex education we have to
make sure they have access to
contraceptives that's that makes all the
sense in the world I was really really
blown away by the Obama administration
last year when they had made the
decision that even though the FDA has
said that it's not a health risk we're
going to make sure that anyone under the
age of 17 still needs a prescription to
get their hands on it how the hell does
like a 15 year old or a 16 year old get
their hands on a prescription within 70
72 hours so you can get plan b and make
sure they don't get prime and especially
in a society where we have so much guilt
related to sex a 15 year old is most
likely not going to her parents to say i
had sex and I gotta get a pill within
the next 24 hours etc etc so what do you
think well I would when I was young we
did my girlfriend I did Plan C which was
horseback riding oh that's a little
different you don't need a prescription
for that no no well you do need some
sort of license to get on a horse do
they really know you show up and give
the guy five bucks out over this year
that's for anyway uh yeah it sounds
crazy that they would know somehow
somehow terminating a pregnancy before
it starts is somehow worse than a
teenager actually carrying a pregnancy
to term that doesn't make any sense to
me write it it's it's all backwards I
don't even know the judge had this kind
of power to do this though the judge
said you've got to start making this
available there
I was like can you do that as it's those
crazy activist judges yes what they
always say right it's an activist judge
so yeah yes finally it's a common sense
judge it makes all the sense in the
world I'm glad that he made this ruling
and who knows if this is something
that's actually going to be appealed or
anything like that hopefully not but I
and the ideas the conservatives are
afraid that if this is available the
teenagers that they're going to have
more sex cuz now they can get rid of
their pregnancy right I said cuz that's
like the coolest thing to do is get rid
of a pregnancy as an abortion or take a
plan B which is but now what's the do
you know how that works Plan B isn't a
hormone that yes so I if i'm not
mistaken what happens is it kind of
stops you from ovulating and let's say
you're already ovulating and that egg
the sperm goes into the egg whatever uh
it's yeah what's the correct term of
saying that way to immortalize fertilize
thank you I'm like our why am I
forgetting this word so the egg gets
fertilized it does something to the
uterus so the egg cannot implant itself
to the uterus oh yeah um so I think
that's the reason why conservatives have
an issue with that because they see that
fertilized egg as life right moment of
conception right so isn't this one of
these things that should have nothing to
do with government like shouldn't is
completely separate from this discussion
yes what does the government have to do
with this and but yet it automatically
is in the discussion because that's
because right world we live in people
like rick santorum live in our country
right yeah i think that he even thinks
that contraception is bad that's it is
wrong yeah it's not right contraception
this is his own words so we live in a
country with religious crazies and we
have to coexist somehow and the way we
do it is we have good judges tell him to
shut the [ __ ] up yeah and we push for
legalization of marijuana which makes us
a little more tolerant of them yes I am
I'm pushing forward sure yeah but
actually you hit on something I want to
talk about which is this idea that
the Republicans the right-wing they seem
to care more about the fetus than they
do once this child is in the actual
Thank You universe once it's out then
then suddenly how it's gonna be paid for
any that they don't really care about
but they care about it when it's up in
here let me jump in about this
hypocritical aspect of Republicans so
they always say like we care about the
baby we care about the life how could
you get rid of the life and then they
want to cut the same government programs
that would help the baby if he or she is
born to a poor family right and a lot of
times that's what happens with women who
really really don't want to have the
baby they want to get an abortion it's
because they know they don't have the
financial stability to raise the child
uh and another very recent example was
this representative in Arizona she was
testifying about abortion and she
actually shared her personal story where
she had an abortion and she's now
getting death threats from pro-life
people because that makes a lot of free
converts right you're pro-life but
you're threatening to kill someone
because of a decision that they made in
their life years ago this has a little
Westboro Baptist Church kind of theme to
it bonobos calm is the official
outfitter of the Ruben report enter code
trr 20 for twenty percent off your first
purchase